no dear seven years when I came out here
you know that I was so wide I wanted it
so bad i was so passionate I've worked
hard it just says paid off so I'm taking
off
I just wanted to let you know
that I've always believed
did you ever wonder before this point
like what if you can quit and you can
walk back and you can see I gave it my
all I gave it my seven years but the
passion will still be down there so deep
and you'll feel it every day and you
wonder why did I walk away when seven
years plus one day I could have had it
definitely he definitely was not
supposed to be like this
if there's anything inside you that
still feels that say me that got you
come out here to be an actor in the
first place then you you have to stick
with it
I said I'm staying in LA
what would you say